the CDC says it's open to using those
anybody test to get Americans back to
work if the results can prove that
employees are immune to the corona virus
right now anybody test only determine if
you've had the virus but in a time when
so much is unknown the tests have given
closures some who were previously sick
who didn't have answers and that
includes our own Jericka Duncan and
Michelle Miller I knew I wasn't feeling
like myself so with everything that was
going on I thought this probably is a
good time I'm early enough in this
pandemic to possibly get a test the
emergency room staff there told me that
they had a short supply and that was
after waiting for almost four hours for
them to tell me to go home and act as
though I had coronavirus I woke up with
a splitting headache a backache and just
this incredible fatigue and it took
three days for me to try to get a test I
couldn't get one either like many
Americans neither myself nor Michelle
could get tested for Kovac 19 back in
March we were told we didn't meet the
CDC guidelines or there were simply not
enough tests to go around to date
roughly 12 and a half million
coronavirus tests have been performed in
the US according to the Kovac tracking
project at most that's enough for about
four percent of the population weeks
after falling ill both Michelle and I
turned to a telehealth company to help
us get antibody tests because at the
time in April those tests were hard for
us to find I called five of my doctors
none of them had the test I went to
three places that did have the test I
could not get the test from them but to
be quite frank we were able to get a
test because you know our own health
this week the CDC addressed antibody
testing in the president's plan to
reopen America it says those tests may
play a role in a back to work strategy
if they can be reliably
linked to immunity but it also
emphasizes there are many unknowns about
the testing those unknowns have
researchers at the University of
Minnesota recommending against using
antibody tests in a workforce setting
for now authors of the report out
Wednesday expressed concern about
accuracy and if a positive test actually
means you're immune from the virus while
it's unclear if antibodies confer
immunity and if they do how long it
could last
experts say the results can bring peace
of mind please do draw some reassurance
reduce anxiety gain knowledge and
understanding from these test results
but don't trust them 100% to suggest
that you're off the hook in terms of
protecting yourself or protecting others
all bandaged up took less than two
minutes
I just wanted an answer and I for the
antibodies having it in surviving it
I just feel somewhat empowered although
I still social distance and I still were
masked that's the work gloves when I go
outside private labs like quest and
LabCorp have been pushing to get more of
those antibody testing out there those
two labs combined have done more than
1.5 million tests antibody tests and
really Gail this is about connecting to
with the very people that we are talking
about talking to there has been no other
time that I've ever felt so connected
when we say that we are all in this
together it's so true jury can I have to
say I envy you in Michelle I took the
antibody test I was negative which means
I've had no exposure and haven't had it
and I was so disappointed because I too
was feeling something and I thought
maybe I've already had it and survived
it so I'm really happy that you guys got
the results that you wanted I'm a little
jealous too but glad you all are okay